so Donald Trump was asked real questions
by a female reporter during yesterday's
White House coronavirus press briefing
he was visibly rattled he pulled the who
are you with condescending question then
he tells her to relax then he tells her
she's being too loud these are all
classic moves by Republican politicians
against female reporters let's get right
into it this is from CBS News why did
you wait so long and why did you not
have social distancing until Mario 64
you would this is how Republican men
often react to real questions from
female journalists those entitled women
who do they think they are who are you
with do you work here could you possibly
be a real reporter disgusting Republican
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
did essentially the same thing recently
this was just a few weeks ago remember
and none of the debate had been held in
public there is virtually no public
debate on what looks to be the largest
bill in American history can you explain
why that was and should the public have
had more time to understand what this
bill is that is meant to help them the
American people so that's now a classic
move that's part of the orthodoxy who
you with do you work here so then this
continues and as Trump lies and doesn't
answer Jiang's questions she doesn't let
him get away with it and so then Trump
pulls the relax card relax sweetie
you're getting all worked up about what
the men are doing in the room take a
look at this so if you look at what I
did in terms of cutting off
or banning China from coming in
Nationals but by the way not Americans
who are also nice generationally just
relax nice and easy nice and easy just
relax
this is not how Trump treats male
reporters this entire patronizing
supercilious behavior and then the
cherry on top is that Trump tells her to
keep her voice down I did not all I have
to do is look anybody new it just are
you ready how many cases were in the
United States what I did my bed how many
people had died in the United States did
you know how many how many how many
cases were in the United States I did a
ban keep your voice down so we don't
often do these stories about just like
this guy's clearly just being a
misogynist but this is clearly one of
those stories and how brilliant would it
have been if Wei Jia Jiang had said how
dare you do you speak to your mistresses
that way and of course she never would
have been allowed back in the press room
obviously notice that even despite all
of this Trump never answered her actual
question which was why were you doing
huge rallies in February despite having
our first case in January and Trump
won't answer and instead attacks or
three times asking who are you with
saying nice and easy nice and easy relax
and then telling her to keep her voice
down and the voice down thing is
actually interesting dr. Burks has a
similar voice to Wei Jia Jiang it's just
their voices right and I've never
commented on this because it's quite
irrelevant in fact but during my live
streams whenever dr. Burks speaks I see
people in the live chat saying ooh
doctor dr. Burks talks so loud and she's
so screw and whatever and I don't find
it worthy of comment and it does strike
me as sort of misogynistic in nature but
that's what makes this all the more
absurd here that the problem is Wei Jia
Jiang's voice when dr. Burke speaks with
the same voice the difference as when
Trump says keep your voice down it's not
actually about Jiang's voice it's about
the words and the questions that she's
asking in case in point right when
extremists Network Oh a n they're
reporters often have to yell from the
back of the room because they don't
actually have a seat
at these press briefings so they're
yelling questions from the back they
just are asking softball questions so
Trump instead of saying keep your voice
down to the oen reporters says what a
nice question he's actually done it a
bunch of times
it would have been just delightful to
see another reporter say mr. president
or sir as he likes to say is it
appropriate to tell a reporter doing her
job to relax and keep her voice down or
is that the exact patronizing behavior
that has led to you giving mistresses
six-figure payouts to keep their mouths
shut
of course that reporter also would have
been kicked out of the room now last
thing on this not not to psychoanalyze
this but Trump seems like a guy who
doesn't really have meaningful
relationships with women Melania Trump
included by the way nor with his
mistresses as evidenced by giving them
six-figure payouts there seems to be an
insecurity there with women where Trump
becomes threatened by women who are
assertive and confident like WA Jia
Jiang who also have the potential of
making Donald Trump look really bad
which she did by the way effortlessly
and the whole point of trumps answers is
to make her seem like she's out of line
which she's not and then in the end the
Trump supporters who were tricked by
Trump into voting for him in the first
place they're posting all over the
internet the reporter is out of line and
she's merely trying to embarrass
embarrass the president it's called
doing journalism and it really exposes
Trump just being fundamentally
threatened essentially by strong women
who are not just cowering down and
accepting a payout from Donald Trump as
so many women have done and the
psychoanalysis of Trump right there
today's program was made possible in
part by better help.com slash Pakman
better help is an online service that
gives you access to your own experienced
fully licensed therapist via phone video
and text when you see if there
in person in their office it can take
three weeks on average before you're
able to get in for your first
appointment but with better help you're
matched with a therapist who fits your
needs within just 24 hours and you get
the same professional service and the
best part is that better help is less
expensive than seeing a therapist in
person as well plus you will have
totally unlimited access to the
therapist you can talk to them whenever
you want
on your phone or computer and because
better help believes in what they do
they also have a full money-back
guarantee if you're not happy with the
service
you'll get a full refund no questions
asked all of their therapists go through
an extensive vetting process and are
required to have at least three years of
experience before joining better help so
you know you're getting someone who's
fully qualified to help you but if you
don't think that your therapist is a
good fit better help lets you switch to
someone new at anytime if you've been
thinking about getting involved with
therapy you should really check out
better help just click the link
underneath this video